افاده مراسل جزيره باصابه عدد من
الفلسطينيين بالرصاص المعدني المغلف
بالمطاط واخرين بالاختناق بالغاز المسيلي
للدموع خلال مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه عقب خروج مسيرات اسبوعيه
مناهضه الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه
وافاد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
تعاملت مع نحو 20 فلسطينيه اصيبوا
بالاختناق بالغاز في قريه بيت دجن وبلده
بيتا الجنوبيه نابلس كما اصيب خمسه
فلسطينيين على الاقل بالرصاص المعدني
المغلف بالمطاط وعاشرات اخرون بالاقتناق
في قريه كفر قدوم شرقيه قلقيليه بعد خروج
المسيره الاسبوعيه المناهضه الاستيطان
كما افاده مراسل الجزيره بان سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه هدمت بيوتا متنقله
اقامتها عائلات مستوطنين ليله الماضيه على
اراضي قريتي جريش وقصره جنوب الشرقيه
نابلس مضيفه الغربيه وكانت قوات كبيره من
شرطه الاحتلال وصلت الى الموقع حيث رفض
المستوطنون اجزاء المنطقه احتجاجا على
قرار الجيش الاحتلال ازاله البؤره
الاستيطانيه الجديده
[موسيقى]
ما اسفر عن اصابه مستوطنين
واكله وزير الامن القومي
غفير قد طلب من وزير الدفاع يعافلام
عن هدم البؤره الاستيطانيه